we murder conviction all right thank you
so thank you to the organizers reminding
me and thank you everyone for waking up
and coming so i'll tell you about to
round and pc via multi key fully
homomorphic encryption this is joint
work with protein Mukherjee who's here
in the audience is going to be a postdoc
here at Berkeley next year all right so
multi-party computation we all know what
it is we have some number of parties
they have inputs x1 x2 x3 and so on they
want to compute some function f apply to
these inputs and they're going to do
this by running a protocol the goal of
this protocol is that everyone should
get the output and nothing else about
the input should be revealed to the
other parties and here I'm going to
assume setting with many parties and an
arbitrary number of corruptions I'm not
assuming honest majority or anything
like that and so this is a question it's
been studied for since the 80s for this
dog the main question that we're going
to address is what's the minimal round
complexity of multi-party computation
what's the can construct NPC with a
minimal number of rounds around just
consist of all parties broadcasting a
message to all other parties without
waiting for each other okay so valleys
and Bob send a message to each other at
the same time that's one round it Valley
sends a message to Bob and then bob has
to respond to it depending on what he
got that's two rounds that's how you're
counting grounds so that's the main
question what's the wrong complexity
another side question us or less
quantitative more qualitative want to
construct MPC you directly using fhe
techniques without going through things
like oblivious transfer in g MW so sort
of different way of doing it
okay so what do we know about round
complexity so ideally two rounds is the
best we could hope for we know we can't
do one round on the other hand if you
look at the old protocols the original
GM w they take many rounds proportional
to the circuit size but it's been known
for a while since the 90s that you can
actually do a constant number of rounds
and I think the constant isn't written
anywhere but if you ask the Oracle yuval
he'll tell you it's for and so we know
how to do that from just oblivious
transfer more recently we know how to do
three rounds from lwe using fully
homomorphic encryption techniques and
even two rounds from
indistinguishability obfuscation but the
question is can we do two rounds without
office keishon can we do it for more
static techniques and just some caveats
all these results are in the common
random string model this is actually
needed for malicious security I don't
think it's needed for semi honest but
the results that these two results do
need it even for semi honest and also we
require newsx to get malicious security
in addition to the assumptions that are
here for semi honest we don't need
mystics and so the main result of this
dog is I'll show you how to do two
rounds from learning with errors
assumption instead of obfuscation can
just that from LW okay so let's start
with a template how would you do
multi-party computation from fully
homomorphic encryption and full homer
fink rip just seems like this powerful
primitive but it's not clear how to npc
who chooses the key who you know who
well that's the main thing who chooses
the key really and who decrypt okay so
here's an idea for how to do it in the
in the beginning the parties will run
some sort of distributed key generation
protocol for an fhe schemes where they
somehow agree on a common public key and
they each get a secret chair of the
secret key in and out of NC Cruickshank
okay so somehow they do that and then
each party i will just encrypt its input
X I under the common public key
broadcast that cipher text once that's
done the party scan homomorphic Lee
compute the function so there's a
deterministic procedure every party can
just do it individual and get the same
answer so get the same ciphertext C star
that encrypts the output of the function
and then the parties can run a
distributed decryption protocol where
they use the shares of the seeker
key to somehow recover the output in
plain text okay so that's the template
how do we actually instantiate this well
it turns out that if you use specific
fully homomorphic encryption schemes the
one from brach risky vodka telethon in
breckenridge entry Vikon telethon then
you can actually directly construct
these distributor key generation and
decryption protocols with one round each
that's for specific schemes and then if
you instantiate it in this framework you
can get a three round multi-party
computation protocol so this is
something we showed in a joint work with
usher of jane lopez alt tremor and by
continent okay so that lets you do three
on MPC from lwe can we somehow reduce it
to two rounds well which one should we
get rid of what should we get rid of
here I'm going to try to get rid of the
first round okay so we're not going to
somehow run a distributor key generation
well what does that mean so now each
party will just choose its own
individual publicly secret key pair
without coordinating and I'll just
encrypt its input under its own public
key and broke has that cipher text and
what we want now somehow be able to take
these ciphertext are encrypted under
different completely different keys
uncoordinated and somehow still be able
to compute on them and what do we get at
the end some ciphertext that encrypts
the output of the computation but under
all the public keys right so no
individual party can decrypt it at this
point but this means that somehow it
encrypt in such a way that with all the
secret keys together you could decrypt
it okay so this is just a one-round here
and then the parties will run some sort
of a distributed decryption where you
take all the secret keys together but in
a distributed way and just get the
output just decrypted out so so what do
we know about this primitive this kind
of multi key fully homomorphic
encryption I mean it doesn't follow from
standard fhe but it was a notion that
was defined by this work of La Lopez
ultra Marin biker telethon and they
showed how to constructed using an
untruth type assumption okay so they
constructed it but unfortunately there
was no nice distributed decryption with
all the keys together
could decrypt but there was no nice way
to do it in a distributed way in fact
the way they suggested to do it is to
run the three-round protocol from the
previous slide that was the best way to
do a distributed decryption more
recently there's a paper that showed how
to do multi key fhe from just the
learning with error assumptions as a
paper by clear and mcgoldrick it's a
paper that apparently print about a year
ago in there for a while and when i
first came out it's an exciting result i
really wanted to understand it but
somehow there's a lot of algebra i
couldn't get through it and maybe
arrogant i served wasn't really sure of
it if it's something that there's a real
result their project was visiting me at
Northeastern sigh sort of assigned this
to him you know can you please read this
and try to figure it out and eventually
figured out there's a really good idea
there I took him longer to convince me
but we start simplifying it and
simplifying it and I think by this point
we actually have a simpler version of
this that's easier to present so
hopefully I'll be able to present it all
to you so in this work the main result
is first to simplify the multi key fhe
scheme from this work and then we show
how to do a nice one round distributed
decryption procedure for this particular
scheme and plugging it together we get
to round and pc okay so this is the main
thing i want to take away this this
picture now we're going to get our sort
of hands dirty and go into the algebra
yeah
I do i do because then if I reveal the
secret keys then you could decrypt the
original input right so they that's
right so this notion of multi kfh it
just says you can compute on the
ciphertext and get something but it
doesn't say how do you decrypt it it
just says you there's a way to decrypt
if you have all the secret keys together
they were they didn't care about about
how to decrypt they weren't using it in
the context of MPC we want to use in the
context of MPC so we want to decrypt in
some distributed way without just
revealing the secret keys that's the
that's the difference so this notion
yeah I think it's a good good thing to
emphasize this notion of multi kfh is
interesting even if you don't have a
nice distributed decryption procedure
but you can't use it for two round in
piscina okay so so we're going to start
i'm going to start by describing the
Gentry's the high waters or GSW fully
homomorphic encryption scheme so shy
described at the boot camp we're going
to tell you just refresh your memory for
those little type that were there then
I'm going to tell you how to convert it
into a multi key fhe so this will be a
variant of the clear and mcgoldrick
result simplified and i'll show you how
to built you around MPC from it since
you're using the template we just saw
okay so we're gonna have to do some
algebra so let's see so let's start with
the key generation I'm just describing
right now a single key fhe scheme the
GSW scheme so the public gear will be a
matrix and by a matrix the first n minus
1 rows uniformly random I'm going to
call that B and the last row is going to
be what's called a learning with our
sample so it's going to some linear
combination of these so s times B plus
some error vector okay that's just the
last row of the matrix and the secret
key is a little weird it's going to be
this vector s that denotes a linear
combination negated and one at the end
why am i doing that this is the main
property if you take the secret key t
multiplied by the public matrix a you
get while you get actually this error
vector E and I'm going to get our error
vectors they're small so I'm just gonna
say oh that's close to zero okay so you
get something close to zero
this is the main property to remember
okay so how do we encrypt with that so
the encryption will take the public key
a this matrix on the last slide and just
multiply it by some M by M 0 1 matrix 0
matrix is 0-1 entries can think of that
somehow re randomizing a and then we're
going to add X this is the bit where
encrypting times some matrix G which
I'll call the public gadget matrix I'll
tell you what it is in a little bit ok
but this is the encryption procedure and
here's the main property you should
remember this is the this is the thing
you need to remember for the rest of the
top if you multiply the ciphertext by
the secret key T then T times a is small
right it's close to zero are a small
close to zero so that sort of cancels
out become small and you get x TG so you
get the bit the encrypted bit out x the
secret eng ok so this also lets you
decrypt now if x is 0 this is small if X
is 1 it's big so you can tell the
difference you can decrypt ok so that's
the that's a property I'll tell you a
little more about the gadget matrix will
need to will need to use it I don't I
won't actually care too much about what
exactly it is I'll tell you what what
property it has that's what you need to
know so the main thing is that there's
some efficiently computable function G
inverse so this is not a matrix inverse
these aren't square matrices you can
invert them but we'll sort of cheat and
it'll be a mostly logging in verse so
there's a function that takes an n-by-n
matrix as input and outputs as 01 m by n
matrix and matrix a short entries but
bigger matrix and this property called G
times G inverse of c is equal to C so
you can sort of just think of this as a
matrix inverse and cancel even though
it's not okay those are my properties
and for those that know the way to
implement is the G inverse is actually
the bid decomposition function and then
G consists of powers of 2 its matrix
that has powers of two one two four
eight and so on
okay so now let's see how to do home
morphic operations on this and the
scheme so we have two ciphertext C 1 and
C 2 they encrypt bits x1 and x2 so this
equation holds for each ciphertext this
is the secret key t so how do we add
just add matrix addition okay so T times
the process this you just get x1 plus x2
TG so you have an encryption of x1 plus
x2 multiplication is more interesting
here's what we do to multiply we can't
just multiply the matrices they have
different dimensions but we'll do the
next best thing will do c 1 times G
inverse of c2 okay so what's happening
here if you try to decrypt the C times
well you get DC one that's xdg plus some
air i'm going to write the air
explicitly here because it's good to
keep track of times G inverse of c2 now
G inverse of c2 is short this error is
short so there's sort of going to cancel
out become short so you really get just
X 1 T times T to the G&G and breast
cancer and now TC 2 is X to TG so you
get this ok so this works out and then
you can do our any Homer Figg operations
you want so that's it that's a that's a
fh g scheme for slides know everything
now so let's try to make it into a multi
key version multi version of the scheme
so here's the scenario we have n parties
and they've completely independent well
independent GSW key pairs ok so party I
has secret TI and that's a secret give
party I and I want to talk about the
expanded secret key which would be just
taking all the secret keys and
concatenating them together ok so let me
call that the expenditure could get
somehow belongs to all parties and our
goal will be to take a ciphertext that
belongs to party I just a single party
ciphertext a party of one encrypts and
somehow convert it into this into
something i'll call it expanded multi
key cipher text ok so somehow expand it
so party I cipher texts this property
see such a TI sees xdg where x is the
encrypted bit I want to expand it into
something that looks exactly has the
exact same format like a GSW secret x
but under the expanded ki t star someone
converted into ciphertext
are such a t-star see stars XD star well
not quite G okay everything blows up all
the dimensions are blowing up but some
sort of an expanded version of G that
just looks like this psychology star and
you can have the same g-star inverse so
the same inverse operation works for
g-star so I'm just blowing everything up
all the dimensions increase but if I do
that then I can I can do that for each
of the party ciphertext convert them
into this expanded form and then they
look just like GSW ciphertext just with
bigger dimension so i can do all the
operations home morphic operations of
the expanded ciphertext just like we did
before nothing else changes so the only
question is how to do this expansion how
to take this one party ciphertext and
convert it into this expanded form oh
good so let's do this for just two
parties it'll be easier but you'll have
to believe me I'm not cheating
everything stands naturally to as many
parties as you want things go sort of
proportionally ok so here we have to
keep heirs of two different parties and
I'm going to so I told you that they
should be independently generated I lied
a little okay they're going to use some
common randomness think of it as public
parameters so this matrix be just a
random matrix they're going to use this
to everyone's going to use the same I
think of it as like a generator of a DD
h group or something everyone uses the
same one that's the only coordination
public parameter of the system and
uniformly random string yeah so ok but
they're going to choose the this last
row individual is so different
individual secret keys and individual
public keys ok so this these are the two
properties they satisfy and now the
party one encryption of a bit x is going
to be just like before and GSW so this
is the this is how we did it before but
we're also going to add some extra help
for information I'm going to tell you
what that is later so there will be
something a little more but the main
thing is the is the encryption that we
had before and this is the property that
we analyze the force of you sort this is
how you do decrypt if you multiply by
the secret key of party one you get this
thing now let's do something sort of
beer let's see what happens if you try
to
with the secret gift party too now this
should give you nonsense you're
decrypting with the wrong secret key
gives you mostly nonsense but there's
some sense to the nonsense so what does
it give you it gives you well so what we
can do it so C is this like a one hour +
XG right that's the definition if you do
t 2 times a 1 okay so you get negative s
to be plus b1 okay so you get this thing
times are this random is r + xt 2 X T 2g
now negative s2b is very close to be too
right so you get B 1 minus b2 r plus X T
2g so you get this thing which is what
you want it this would this is what you
would get if the ciphertext was actually
encrypted under public key under party
to ski but you get some blinding factor
that depends on R and the two public
keys so you almost get the right thing
but somehow blind it and of course you
know it has to be blinded you shouldn't
get the right thing so this is what
we're going to do we're going to create
an expanded ciphertext C star that's
going to look like this it's going to
have just see on the diagonal at some
matrix D at the top again I'll tell you
what D is exactly later but let's see
what properly we need from D then we'll
see how to do the help information d so
I want to make sure that you know this
is the equation i want i want to make
sure that if you decrypt with t star the
concatenated key you get the right
answer XD star g star right so that's
the property I want so if you see what
happens I'm so T star Z star just t 1 t
2 c star so t1 gets multiplied by C over
here on the left so you get T 1 see on
the left and you get T 1 D plus D to see
on the right so we analyze both of these
terms so t1 see is just X T 1 G and T to
see is this thing so I need to make sure
that T 1 D plus D to C is this ok so
here's what I need I need to make sure
t1d exactly gets rid of this blinding
factor that we had here ok so again just
to summarize my goal here is to so
there's two things I didn't tell you how
to do I didn't tell you about this
helper info is and I
and tell you how to choose how to create
this matrix D such at this halts now i
want to emphasize actually this is
important this helper information that
the party one creates at the beginning
it's stolen that kind of party to party
to isn't around during encryption time
okay so this this helper info doesn't
depend on party to you don't know his
public key or anything like that but
over here when you create d when you
expand the ciphertext you do know what
party to this so this happens at
evaluation time so here you do know the
public you've punished so again let me
just summarize the goal now that we have
here so given a party want ciphertext
and some helper information we want to
find a matrix and later so this helper
information doesn't depend on this this
part over here at all but later when you
get this part you want to find d such
that this holds okay that's our goal
that's our only goal we do that we're
done so and here's the idea the helper
information is just going to be GSW
encryptions of all of these of the
randomness in the ciphertext so I'm
encrypting a ciphertext as my bit I care
about and then I encrypt all the
randomness that's all I'm doing under my
own key under party wants key okay so
that doesn't hurt security I mean you're
just encrypting the randomness
everything semantically secure that's
fine now to get this matrix D we're
essentially going to do some sort of a
homomorphic computation on this
encrypted randomness so we're going to a
home morphic computation we're on these
ciphertexts that encrypts rij to get a
matrix D which essentially looks like
encryption of this value b2 minus v1 are
now I'm cheating a little like the teeth
the star disappeared the G disappeared
so you're going to have to believe me
that this is doable ah let's see yeah I
don't think I've enough time today so
you'll have to believe me that this is
doable but it really follows the same
approach as the standard GSW Homer Figg
operations we somehow taking the
encryption of the random is our bit by
bit and combining them to get this I
need to like cancel out the G so I'll
just multiplied by G inverse on the on
the right
okay so that's it that's the whole idea
that's the multi key fhe so now let's
talk about how to do a decryption
distribute the decryption of this so
let's again look at the equation so we
have this expanded secret key t star and
if you just want it to decrypt in a non
distributed way you could just multiply
T star times T star and get you know see
if this is smaller big if you thought
about doing this in a distributed way
yeah that's right i don't need any
special property there's no extra secure
sumption this is just secured by the GSW
fhe security which falls from lwe yeah
okay so if I didn't care about secure
decryption just wanted to decrypt in
some way this is what I do but you can
see even if we somehow distributed this
procedure this computation that would be
terrible because just revealing XD star
g star if X is 1 you learn all the
secret keys see stars the concatenation
of all the secrets i'm from t star g
stud you start again you can learn
everything so that would reveal a lot of
information we can't do that so the
first step is to want to be to somehow
sanitize this ciphertext so we can't we
can't just directly decrypt the
ciphertext just you know even give you
the output of this computation it's too
much information we got sanitized so
what does it mean we're going to just
multiplied by G Star inverse of W where
W is this vector just zeros and Q over
to at the end what does that do well now
if you take T star times this vector C
you get T star Z star d steyn base of W
and essentially you get this thing times
G Star inverse of W so that gives you XD
star w now T star remember of the secret
keys i have one in the last component so
everything will cancel right it's just a
zero so you just get a Q over two so you
just get x times Q over to so you don't
really learn anything more than just X
doesn't depend we got rid of the secret
key here yeah
and I think procedure for for the scheme
for that job you can call it that yeah
yeah so so so I'm saying at least now
it's okay for me to reveal t star see
well not even that is a bit problematic
because there's some error here right
that I don't want to reveal it's not
completely it's not completely
randomization because of error but close
enough okay and so well so now we need
to compute this in a distributed way let
me take this vector C and just write it
down this way so it's an anti little n
times capital and capital n is the
number of parties vector I'm just going
to write it down this way where each
components or corresponds to one party
and then these star C is just the sum of
tea I see I so now we can do this in a
distributed way so what's the distribute
weight each party just outputs a partial
decryption ti times CI so in each party
just add everyone can compute the
sanitized ciphertext a deterministic
procedure then everyone just takes this
component multiplies it by its own
vector and you can add up these partial
decryptions and recover this one extra
thing the partial decryptions you have
to add a little bit of error and this
little bit of error you have to add to
drown out whatever error was contained
in the original ciphertext because that
could be sensitive information too okay
so each party just adds big enough air
to drown this out and here's the
security property you get you can and be
easy to show you can simulate one
party's partial decryption given just
the output X and the secret keys of all
the other parties so you need to serve
know what what everything else is but
that says that if everyone else but one
part is corrupted you'd still I'm not
revealing that one party isn't revealing
anything extra about its secret key
other than the output of the computation
so you can simulate so just to summarize
this is the protocol we had we're going
to just plug in the multi key fhe into
this protocol there's a little bit of a
subtle tea so we actually show this
protocol is secure for all but one
corruptions if you corrupt everyone but
one party seems to be the hardest case
but somehow we actually have a hard time
showing if you corrupt all but
to parties so we need to do some minor
modifications to get that if some of you
are familiar with MPC and you know maybe
we're doing something silly it really
feels like it but for technical reasons
it really seems like we needed this the
other thing is so so far we only get
honest but curious security if you want
to get malicious security will need to
add music tseverywhere so in this round
actually people prove that they did
things correctly won this round do you
prove that you encrypt it correctly so
people prove that they did everything
correctly usually to go from semi honest
and militias you also need to do coin
flipping which would introduce extra
ounce here you don't need to do that
it's pretty easy to see that people use
bad randomness so choose their public
key secret keys badly they're only
hurting themselves not hurting anyone
else ok and a couple of open questions
so one is can we get rid of the common
random string in the honest but curious
setting so we need it because we need
these common parameters that everyone
uses to choose their key pairs can we
get rid of that I don't know how about
be interesting and the other question
even in the semi honest I don't know how
to get rid oh oh yes yes yes it is
there's a lower bound of five rounds yes
because your knowledge 00
okay so no but as far as I understand
you can't do just your knowledge in two
rounds right for from you cannot do zero
nostrils in two rounds SI eres mala okay
maybe I'm likely so all right i'll leave
it in unlikely so and the other
questions can we get two or three rounds
under different assumptions maybe just
oblivious transfers their relays or
maybe it's also unlikely there's some
lower button but that would be
interesting so those are the two main
questions I think are interesting thank
you
generally I want to a multi scheme just
to know in advance everybody's going to
be insisting no no they they don't need
who needs to be they don't need to know
who needs you system they need to know
how many people will be in the system
they need to just know it bound on the
encryption time you need to know how
many parties a maximum number in the
number of parties your support we don't
yes that's right that's that's the case
for the clear McGoldrick and this the
simplified version we give we don't need
to know the bound the disadvantage over
and true is that we need the common
parameters they didn't actually they
didn't need any common parameters this
matrix B so trade-off yeah
that's right just a random random string
here nothing else not that's right in
the malicious case also the CRS of the
music but that could also be random
string any other questions all right
thank